hi guys I'm Ronald from simply learned
and today we are going to do something
very interesting today we're going to go
through some of the applications of
blockchain now before we get into it let
me tell you what exactly is a blockchain
now a blockchain is a list of Records or
blocks which stores data publicly and in
a chronological order now the data of
then these blocks or records are secured
using cryptography they don't have a
central authority controlling them
anyone has access to the data within
this network but not everyone can order
the data and everyone has copies of this
data so now that you know what
blockchain is let's get you to this
video today we will be talking about
blockchain when it's used in supply
chain management blockchain and
cybersecurity how blockchain is used for
voting and other applications of
blockchain so now let's have a look at
supply chain management now let's look
at the scenario before blockchain so
there's a delivery boy bringing john his
order of apples now john thanks him and
sees that his apples are rotten and john
says that he wants his money back
however the delivery boy says he can't
help since he's just the delivery boy
not the person who created the product
so these problems are the ones that we
faced before blockchain but with
blockchain technology there is
traceability across the supply chain
this means that you can trace back to
what happened to the product at each
step of the supply chain blockchain
technology enables these transactions to
be tracked in a very secure and
transparent manner
now some benefits of using blockchain
technology other there's a single record
policy which means there's a single
director throughout the entire supply
chain
there's reduced costs since there's no
requirement for multiple records across
the entire supply chain
there's eliminating error and less human
intervention now the last two points
comes from what in correlation since the
less of the human intervention usually
the less of the amount of error let's
have a look at an example of a supply
chain management so the product starts
from the farm goes through storage
undergoes food processing it's
manufactured distributed given to the
retailer and finally reaches the
customer now in supply chain management
blockchain is able to provide a
permanent record a whole lot of
transparency and the ability to validate
the transactions that are shared across
multiple supply chain partners with
Lock chain the transactions are recorded
in a decentralized distributed ledger
now the advantage of this is that anyone
can verify the authenticity or the
status of a product that is being
delivered now if you want to look at
real life example you have to look no
further than Walmart Walmart is building
a block chain distributed ledger so that
they can connect and track book
suppliers shippers purchases and other
units involved in its supply chain that
are delivering the food product across
China now this is done to reduce the
risk of data tampering or inaccuracy or
inaccuracy now let's have a look at how
blockchain helps cyber security imagine
the scenario where a is sending twenty
dollars to be e cents this money and
this transaction details are stored in
the cloud now what if a hacker hacks the
data within the cloud and tampers this
he tampers this in such a way that he
receives the twenty dollars instead of B
here you can see the hacker being all
smug about it now this is the main
problem with the current banking system
now it is prone to cyber attacks because
it has a centralized network this can
also lead to fraud as well as date of
death cyber attacks are one of the
biggest threats that the public has to
face
however blockchain is a solution that
makes sure that your data is protected
from tampering as well as helps
improving cybersecurity across a number
of different industries some of the
benefits are that it provides high
security with the help of the
cryptography that I mentioned before it
has a decentralized storage quick
transactions which take only about 10
minutes and lower cost as compared to
banking transaction costs now let's look
at the same scenario but with the help
of bitcoins or blockchain now a sending
0.0025 bitcoins to be which amounts to
approximately $20 these bitcoins the
sent and blockchain which is a
distributed ledger distributes the data
across multiple nodes within the network
and secures this data using cryptography
another thing that you have to remember
is that each node has a copy of the
ledger and cryptography protects the
data within it against any changes
making it immutable now imagine a hacker
trying to hack the data here he's
unsuccessful because the peer-to-peer
connection which prevents data from
being altered as well as tampered now
and finally be receives $20 in bitcoins
now for a real life application master
has its own blockchain project where
MasterCard is using blockchain for
sending as well as receiving money it
also allows the exchange of currency
without the need of a central authority
now let's have a look at how blockchain
can help with the wording process
now before blockchain a water would have
to submit their water ID their water IDs
need to be verified and after the
verification the water would submit his
or her word to the EVM or the on tronic
voting machine after that the voting is
complete however it is possible for the
EVM to be hacked
since it's a centralized system this can
lead to some amount of manipulation with
the word count however with the
decentralized system like block shell it
is possible to completely eliminate any
scope of forgery as well as data
manipulation now let's have a look at
how routing can be performed with the
help of blockchain now first the water
downloads the voting application the
water submits a water ID and registers
for the election after the verification
is complete the water has been
authorized to cast his or her boat and
the water submits his or her word
without revealing their identity to the
public now once this water has been
added to the blockchain the information
within the blockchain
can never be erased after this the
officials can call these words knowing
that each ID can be attributed to just
one boat now with blockchain footers can
also count the number of words
themselves using blockchain in the
voting process provides complete
transparency by eliminating any need for
third party systems to be involved along
with that it can also eliminate voter
fraud as well as election rigging it
increases the transparency in the voting
process and reduces the expense of
conducting the elections now in real
life examples me wot which is a token
based blockchain platform works very
similar to that of a digital ballot box
now it protects the integrity of the
word as well as protects the security of
the election process now this is already
implemented in Australia so it's only a
matter of time before this or similar
technologies can be set up across the
world now let's have a look at some of
the other applications there's insurance
where with blockchain they can eliminate
forgery as well as false claims and real
estate where this increases the speed of
the conveyance process and eliminates
any requirement for
money exchanges so if talking about
blockchain and it's applications have
caught your interest I suggest we get on
to simply long calm and check out our
blockchain certification training course
here we provide 50 hours of in depth
learning 40-plus hands-on exercises with
integrated labs 11 practical projects
covering multiple technologies like
aetherium I Bellagio multi-chain and
Bitcoin flexibility to choose your own
class timings case studies and 24/7
support will be covering technologies
like get its helium ganache go doc a
hyper ledger and much more we'll also be
talking about Bitcoin blockchain
etherium deploying smart contracts hyper
ledger blockchain or multi chain and a
whole lot more so why don't you go on to
simply learn comm and get started on
your journey to getting certified and
getting ahead and with that we've
reached the end of this video I hope you
guys found this informative and helpful
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simpler hi there if you
liked this video subscribe to the simple
learn YouTube channel and click here to
watch similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here